ur and
our daily appointment for the
press online and live on bs
today is Friday July 9
like every Friday I would like to
give you an overview of the
president's calendar for the week to come
Monday the president mrs  dhalla she
will receive the
united states treasury secretary janet yellen is the
president of the european central bank
christine lagarde for a
working lunch on tuesday she will receive
the federal president of austria
alexander von der maelen in
the evening she will receive the prime minister
of the  poland mateusz morale there is
what for a working dinner on wednesday
the president will chair the
college meeting and on friday she will be in
dublin ireland as part of her
tour of capitals next generation you
know adalbert shaves enhancement in
braille first  8.7 in the forum des halles
albert
thank you to my feet at the live of his restraint
told me m alas daily news thank you
very much albert before moving on to your
questions i would like to remind you that
the informal meeting
of employment and social affairs ministers
continues today in slovenia a
press conference with commissioner
nicolas schmit will take place after the
meeting around 1 p.m. and with those we
can move on to  your questions then I
start with the questions of colleagues
who are connected the ornais uses the
flower sum that the prince of what to
vaccinate this music 16 king and hinds
judith toxins more than ten minutes
dahinden wants young road middle of this
post by stéphane produced
[Music]
we are expecting
ok lights carry on or we
vaccinate surprise vaccination we say that
would take effect on vocation in date and
not hockey situations here must
return east angus this is your soul and
ste anne to  the word
we are trying customs
yes hello no it was in fact it is
a question about the recovery plan
sorry you sorry we will come back to you
later
angel  locth a vaccination
[Music]
if these dates of application
looking to date but angelo stéphane
but now brad we may agree
it would be what for action of a
story booster dos
bambi would have said yes correct  concludes
sludge treatment
5 you will continue in civilian clothes and all
vaccinated
christian yes hello in fact I have two
questions relating to the vaccine the
first I am very confused about the
Indian version of astrazeneca I
cannot understand what the
problem is  it is not the same
astrazeneca vaccine that is injected into us
today the one that is made in
india
why there are so many problems with
this version 9 of believed to understand that we were
trying to have a maximum of production capacities
or there obviously  there is a doubt that
is expressed by the commission on the
seriousness of this vaccine this vaccine manufactured
in india
is what it really is so that is
my first question my second question
is rather related to the vaccine  ination in
the european union
we see almost everywhere
appearing alarms saying that indeed there
is a slowdown in vaccination campaigns
and that there is a big
imbalance between the member states where
there are some who are ahead others
who  are late but in fact
we worry a lot about the fact that there is
a large part of the population who
received a
gold injection and we saw it clearly with the Prime
Minister of Luxembourg
you had vettel had received an
injection  of astrazeneca and to recover
a very bad version of du duc au
vide that he left on his side for
several days hence the importance
of having the second maxi beyond the
second injection
so I his share is what that
concern me do you think
you will reach your goal of 70%
of adults vaccinated by the end of
the summer or is there starting to
be a doubt that will fuel the
fear of a fourth  wave and
pot repercussions  entirely economic
on the european union thank you thank you
thank you christian before passing the
floor to stéphane maybe two
comments from me
i don't think the commission has
expressed any doubts about the
indian version of the astrazeneca vaccine
simply it  there are formal processes
that must be followed according to
very specific criteria and which
implies that the Indian version
of the vaccine must seek authorization
from the European Medicines
Agency, but stéphane will certainly specify
this with regard to the  objective
allow me to remind you that the objective
that the commission has set is not a
vaccination objective since we
are not responsible for the vaccination policies
of the vaccination campaigns
it is the member states
that we have set ourselves  set at the
level of the European Commission
is to deliver sufficient doses
to the Member States so that they
can fully vaccinate  t 70%
of adults in the european union
are over 18 whether on the basis of two
doses of vaccine when their
third vaccine or one dose of
vaccine as is the case with the johnson &
johnson so we have to
distinguish it because there is still a
certain there may be a delay
between deliveries and and
vaccination on the issue of concern
with regard to vaccination campaigns
our message is the
president has repeated it on
many occasions is
that indeed we must
continue the vaccination campaigns
at the level of the member states in order to
ensure that a maximum of the population
can reach a vaccination
complete as soon as possible because
it is the only way to ensure that
we can deal with the evolution
of the pandemic and keep it under
control
it is true that starting the movement with
a first dose is already important in itself
because we know  it that it
protects in particular from the effects
it often protects from the effects beyond the
disease but it does not offer
complete protection
here after this
somewhat long introduction I give the floor to stéphane
thank you very much there is not much
I  think i can add the first
thing is that indeed as eric
pointed out it is not a question of writing a
doubt as to this vaccine not at all
the company is still able to
submit an application  of recognition
of request for authorization of placing on the
market with elements that it is a
thing
secondly what the hands made
before giving the green light bet on
releasing a vaccine
they check the effectiveness and the safety
vaccines and that also involves a
verification of production procedures,
for example because Emma
wants to be seen to ensure that
mass production continues to guarantee
the safety efficiency of the simple facs to
which Europeans are
therefore entitled  when it comes to a vaccine that
is
produced outside this plh and for which there is
already an authorization
then it is up to the hands to check the
steps that are followed the production processes the
production procedures
once again  to assure
European citizens that the vaccine that
is produced in this factory in
this week at respects the
necessary conditions with
regard to effectiveness and above all that it is
big and so basically have that
vaccines no longer be released and I
think that  'with that I'm finished
christiane I have a follow-up question
yes thank you for enlightening me on the
procedure for the production of the
Indian vaccine I didn't understand very well I
don't know if I'm going alone in all  the
cases me that reassures me no it is a
reflection on the fact that one also
reads everywhere that there are
stocks of unused vaccines in
countries I think that I read something
on spain  do you
care  the fact that you have
delivered well but that the vaccines are not
injected is therefore indeed
that contributes to the slowdown
of vaccination campaigns stéphane I
think that we all know there are two
things on the one hand we have always
emphasized that from our  people what we are
trying to ensure with
vaccine producers is the delivery of a
sufficient number of doses so that we can
all reach the objective of 70%
vaccination of the adult population,
which is important  what remains important
however obviously is that the
member states will do what is necessary to
administer the vaccines which have been
delivered by the vaccine companies
so indeed it is a question of quickly
using the vaccines which have been delivered
this objective of 7  1% is a
very important objective we must all do our
best to achieve it we believe that
with the number of doses that will be
submitted and as the Americans pointed out,
the member states are in m  esure
to achieve
this this objective but it is
obviously necessary that the member states
administer the doses I
remind you that the commissioner who
has made a tour of several
member states where she visits the member states
to see with the states  members and
what are the challenges in what
way can the commission
support member states to ensure,
among other things, that vaccination rates
of 7 years pushing are achieved everywhere in
particular and allow me to add
perhaps christian that what is
classified that we are monitoring the situation
carefully
we must not draw conclusions too
quickly
with regard to the doses that are in
stock in the member states
this may be linked to a whole series of
factors
there the fact that we do not already have
reaches a large number of
two people and that we are
now reaching sections of the population
who are perhaps more reluctant to
vaccination can avoid effe  ctively
be a factor but there may
be others so we should not draw
too hasty conclusions
that said that being said and I believe that
stéphane in mentioning the fact that
ms khayati 17 in close contact with
the member states
underline this  we are monitoring the
situation closely to ensure that
the doses delivered can actually
be used as quickly as
possible and in good conditions
christian you have another
follow-up question
in fact no it's not a question it's
just a comment  it will be brief it is
on this one we will be able to compensate it is
the fault in brussels
we are always delighted when you say it we
are even more delighted when you write it
christian so do not hesitate to nay we come
back to you  since now you
have a question about vaccines I thought I
understood we're talking a good here is my
camera and on my laptop and
it's messing everything up I'm sorry I'm
not missing yes in fact I have a question
about  good to communicate to you on the number
of doses delivered
I believe from what I
saw earlier that we put at 480 million of 481
million doses delivered therefore by
the au
to the member states the question that  I
wonder it's these 481 million doses that
can vaccinate
how many people because at a
number of doses in reality it doesn't
mean much said johnson & johnson
so would it be possible to
know how many  people it makes it possible to
vaccinate
thank you very much agree one first
thing it's obvious it's not the
European Union that delivers the doses it's
the pharmaceutical companies I
think it goes without saying that's
what you  meant
actually with regard to the number
of people that this allows you to
vaccinate there is a difference between the
number of doses delivered the number of
people since three of the four
vaccines that have been authorized by the
hands require doses so the only
company that  deliver  t vaccines
requiring a single dose it's johnson
and johnson
so that's what makes the difference
stéphane can we give an
approximate figure in any case
with regard to the question dan you have
just explained éric le  challenge because it
is indeed two types of vaccines
some vaccines need two
doses other vaccines need windows
and it all depends on the number of doses that
were delivered by these two groups to
do the calculations so  I don't have an
exact calculation here allow me to
check maybe I could
give you something
in the meantime you have to put a little
passion music on the floor while
stéphane I do the music while
his calculations which is certain  is that
the vast majority of the doses that have
been delivered are doses of a vaccine
requiring two injections
johnson johnson as you know has only delivered
so far a
relatively small number of two doses and  t
so it's mainly the number
divided by two with a certain
variation to take into account johnson &
johnson
here I think we will look at you
later if stéphane can
give you the exact calculation you must not
forget that these figures evolve
daily
so  it's not something that we
track that we
have a precise number for every day
so I don't see any more questions
on vaccines and so anne I'll
pass the floor back to you for the question on
national plans for  recovery
yes then I had because in question
on the national recovery plans
want to know I believe that this is the case
in any case at least for three
member states which are the member states which
do not yet have him who do not  have not
yet submitted their recovery plans to
the commission I am sorry if I ask you
the question again forgive me how
many countries
finally if the question that asks you
again the question how many countries we  t
asked for an extension period and what
are they
I take the opportunity to
ask you or not but on
hungary has hungary made a request
for extension the
examination period of his clan and then last
question how many plans have been
approved by the commission so
they are now being
studied dare i say to the board assesses
to the board assessed by the board thank
you thank you so with regards to the last
question we have done so
far sixteen visits with the
president and therefore the answer if I'm not
mistaken and 16 plans that have been
approved with regard to the other
questions I give the floor to martha
yes thank you with indeed the first
number that you gave completely
correct so the commission has  already
approved 16 plans this now we
have to be analyzed by the council
is so you may know that there is indeed
an ecofin council meeting which will take
place next week to approve
we hope more  s plans finally
that we presented to the council
so we still have a plan that we
analyze which we were therefore submitted
by the member states and we hope to
receive another 3 of them so there are three states
that have not yet submitted  their plan at
the commission is it's about
malta bulgaria and the netherlands
regarding your question on the extensions
so as i had the opportunity
to indicate this week so there are five
countries which  informed us that they
would like an extension
of the commission's evaluation period
which is which is two months
it is poland
estonia romania sweden finland
and i believe so  it's your last
question concerned the Hungarian case
so we have it for the moment I have
no new information provided in
relation to what was said
this week
we continue to evaluate
the plan place  according to the criteria
set out by the aref regulations
and therefore we hope to  sure to wrap up
this assessment as soon as possible
thank you thank you very much are there any other
questions on the national
recovery plans for us today please
keep your hand up that
if so derek you just drop so
oliva started  the co leaders and we will see
after you have a problem with the source 2
microphones and I will take the opportunity to
pass the floor in the room to
isabelle hello it was about hungary
also I had asked you for
clarifications to hungary is it  that
it happens in a dialogue is what
you expect from the written clarifications
how finally I would like to know
how it is going more concretely
the days to come knowing that on
this date of July 12 when
you decide is what it is  are you the
one asking for an extension is
it hungary that has to ask for an
extension or can you legally
continue without it being
formally requested thank you hammer
that's it q  we heard thank you for your
question isabelle so in fact the
regulations provide that throughout the
period of analysis of
desplanques that the commission receives there
is a dialogue a close dialogue with in
particular it is once
again article 19 which  specifies and which says
that when it carries out the
evaluation the commission acts in
close cooperation with the member state concerned it
can make observations or
request additional information
I continue reading this article
which says the member state concerned  provided
the additional information
requested is little modified his plan for
the recovery of art in lézignan if
necessary, including after
presenting this one officially so that
's really the legal framework in
which we find ourselves
and therefore who who applies  the this
current case after the discussions is experiencing
with all member states in this
period take the form of
different both written exchanges  speeches of the
meetings so that I think it is
natural and once again the regulations
specify that the member state concerned and the
commission can if necessary
agree to extend the deadline set for
the variations for a
reasonable period so what is important
here it is that indeed it must be
a common agreement of the two parties for
this extension
thank you thank you very much
oliva well
yes now it works thank you
also on this
marta who said that we continue
to evaluate the plans in fact the
Hungarian plan is this  that to analyze the the
original plan where the in fact the
answers or the explanations that the
Hungarians sent consoling the fight
against corruption etc
because the recommendations of
2019 2020 was quite precise in fact we
can read in the two reports that in
made in hungary there is no
political will to attack
high level corruption we all know the framework of the
son-in-law of prime minister orban
n  necessary for olaf's
investigation the investigation by the hungarian authorities which
was completed so i would like to
know if you have received any answers from
the hungarian government
on the issue of corruption and if
in fact it will be necessary to go through
the  weekly by the chief of staff or if
you are confident agree with
with the answers of the hungarians if the
decision will be taken directly biya in
fact
in fact in the written procedure
thank you with regard to the last
question oliver the commission to
different procedures  of decision but
when it is the written procedure it
also obviously implies that the
cabinets responsible and the
commissioners responsible give their
approval so there is not
really a difference in terms of substances
years which depending on the procedure who
is who is  follow-up with regard to the
other questions I will pass the floor back to
martin
yes thank you winter so you did well
to remind us that this  what is
important in the context of the analysis of
the Hungarian plan is indeed the
recommendations that have been put to
Hungary in the years 2019 2020
and as you have said yourself the
recommendations that Hungary has received
relate to many subjects
but also in particular linked to corruption
a second element which is important
in our analysis is the fact that
each country must put in place an
adequate control and audit mechanism
precisely to prevent cases of
corruption  and fraud so
effectively we have two
important criteria which will be applicable in
the analysis of the right plan which we
of course look at in detail
and indeed we do our
analysis on the basis of all
the information provided to us
so at this stage  here again we
continue this in-depth analysis of the
plan and hope to find a conclusion
as soon as possible
thanks to him it is a question of follow-up
yes then if  I understood correctly the deadline
of July 12 will not be held it would
not be possible for the commission of 30
this decision until Monday and why
the Hungarians did not ask for an
extension of the in fact
for for their answers as as the
50 round country
thank you martin thank you winter so i
will not speculate regarding 2
for hungarian part why did
not ask for the extension so i want
of course you have to address
hungarian authorities about this in this  what concerns
us the date of finalization of our
analysis once again I am not a
culé expert at this stage when
can we finalize it
so that's all I can say is it
not me thank you thank you
so I  see others to remove I
guess on this theme
tommaso season 6 of weeds not me it
up is requested in the mail in a
coach where buddha goes on date at one
stop motion to each prime minister in
genzyme quartet we live  ten visits
will take free  cooling everything says shah joy
of the martha yields 1.98 so quickly a
turning point visited six teams society
nineteen we have it so it member states
to go including on yawns life commission
otherwise this focus
martha no he says
indication thanks as to  a question
about the plans yes it's a good day
eric and wants a wii go great yes
my question to go there it's not a
question here a question
a bit too technical but it's
possible because is it  it is possible
in the text in the regulations on the
recovery plan that there are only 26
payments that can be launched before the
end of July as indicated and that the 27th
there we live arrive later know page
I reread from rules the bronze  I do
n't really understand how it works and
if for example your question in the event that
a recovery plan with is refused
is that the money from kiel and sinks to the
point of believing that this country must
be distributed in paris at the foot of the
distribution  in the other p  Let me
remind you that in any case there are three
plans that have not yet been submitted
so we are not in a
situation of 26 plans submitted and
potentially approved before the
end of July so that shows that
the two are unrelated the deadline for the
end of the deadline the possibility of making
installments and the fact that all the
member states and sunu have their plans but I
pass the floor to martha for the rest
yes thank you indeed that
may allow me to  clarify the procedure
with regard to the first installments
for the countries
so again here the regulations
give us different stages and
also the different deadlines for the
next stages
in clear the commission must not wait
for all the plans to be submitted or
approved to start
disbursements so that's an
important point to emphasize from the start so as
soon as the board has approved
the commission's proposal for a
plan  national the next step is
for the commission to conclude a
financing agreement or a loan agreement with
the member state concerned if it were to be
requested will apply for a loan after the
signature of this document to the commission
must make a first payment of  13% to
this country and that in the if possible in
the
- so that that's also prescribed
by the regulations and so that
means that for some countries
actually also the council approves
the plans next week those are
steps that  which will have to take place in
July so we hope to start the
first disbursements for his
feet there in the second part of
July thank you thank you anne again on
this subject I think yes so still a
question on the Hungarian recovery
plan to understand  in fact
what there is a problem on the hall on the
control patients the system of control
of the funds in any case there could
be a problem the control of the lights
is not  robust enough have to
say no that it is one of the criteria a
criterion obviously very important but
for a plan not if they have to
respect this criteria out of eleven from
memory so does that mean that
it necessarily means  to say that there are other
criteria on which it does not work no
for hungary
as a reminder we said here on the
podium that the commission is in the process
of analyzing the whole plan we
are not going into details in
regarding the different types of
criteria that are mentioned in the r f
that are being discussed and as
always we will only provide an analysis
once this has been completed
on all of the criteria derek
my time is absolutely perfect  thank you
hello eric I would like to talk about the bric
site and more specifically about the
financial regulations
we see that the British treasury are
starting to cringe on the
amount which is announced in the
consolidated budget of the eu 2014  2020 if I
understood correctly of 47.5 billion euros I
wanted to ask you if you could
explain to us precisely how this
sum had been
calculated if it is correct to say that it
is higher than the estimates and then
if it is  negotiable and negotiate thank
you thank you derek we were still on the
questions on the national
recovery plans so allow me before you end
to ask balaj to answer your
question to see if there are other
questions on this subject
it doesn't  is not the case I have to relearn
to look if there are hands raised in the
room it's what makes me happy besides
I don't see any other so
indeed balazs to you
hello so indeed June 30th
like every year  we have published the
annual accounts of the european union
so it is a 200 page report in
which we find information in
relation to the financial obligations of
the united kingdom towards the european union and
in relation to the financial obligations
of the union  n european towards the
united kingdom after after the exit so the
figure you quote is correct
so it is an amount of 45 of 47
5 billion euros that the united kingdom
will have to pay towards the budget of
the european union for the
next few years so what are the
sandstones are the elements which breaks down
into two this figure there are two
mainly so on one side there are those
called the rest said they
must therefore  these are the payments that
have to be made against
commitments that were made before
31 january 2000 2020 and there is also
the uk contribution towards the
pensions and health
insurance health insurance
health insurance scheme  of the
European Union and therefore of course all these
calculations were made in line with
the withdrawal agreement of which the
vitrollais grinnt
so here I wanted to add 700
obviously must not be peace in a
short time but it was about we do not
keep a per  iodine for several years
so that's what we can say for
the moment
thank you it's a pleasure to pass the
word on to its subsidiaries
thank you it's me where is tired f
austria a hairdresser is there was this goal
new soul
wintek  insight
ok we say uk jo in sochi and rio sunday
the back to business cause is too strong
it will have to leave in its
context
in front of think you're the rileys we say
we don't expect
[Music]
[  Music]
there is a frustration know it really
know what to do and between sums
miscalculated we are short and louis fails
of calculation is a city of 50 kw h a
young man in september
[Music]
four people ski jumping
in china we say kent region
ok ok ok if we know a come
back to thank you for is now 5th
around march and if there is goal
yes and no if john collins canker sore life
weekly meeting cabinet a lack of care
biden y today  today we tuesday in
traunstein then we from another
release while giada  from mass
graves we qu to indy its body of list
of points planned witches axa this beautiful
Monday internet on all fronts
however if the future meetings and the
indicative indicative price list and
many many things cannelito bing fraud
at the tray
wright food and  ministers until
6 am grind entertainment
i am olives formulation
to oppression formulation new world ok
we we stick to the docks ice
mismatch sorghum beat lorenzo with
what about m
which is procedure
layton all around the sayings of
everyone who fasts robin would have said of the
president or president
hendry and drate or candid this one is
composition of our customers from matthews
italy doubina wine to two year delay
pass requests new any
commission to recommend to all
sonic riders bogdan
ok there we go  sees we come back to you
position by felt visitors
stephen options consistory club x
pect this same stadium
carsten schloter police note done  like
a chewing gum monitoring grids closed
the latitudes and event for cutie
i feel where he wins the verona open
spect crafton lorenzo the urkaine good
deal estimates a kentucky court
adequate timing attrition
this commission would have said working own
best of been listed cgt  sncf for the 5th
time by alberte des patricians must
skillful
[Music]